historically Wars were begun by a formal
declaration of war these would often
come in two forms one via direct
communication with a foreign government
by delivering a letter or telegram or
two through a government minister asking
for the passport of a foreign ambassador
thereby revoking the diplomatic immunity
but since the Second World War there
have been very few formal declarations
of war and none by the major global
powers which raises the question why not
why did nations stop formally declaring
war
so to give examples of why we're going
to look at two conflicts from the Cold
War the Vietnam War between the USA and
North Vietnam and the Falklands War
between Britain and Argentina be aware
that the general reasons for their not
being declarations of war in these
conflicts can be applied to most other
conflicts too so the first major
difference between the world pre and
post World War two is that a new
international framework existed the
United Nations and the UN had very
strict guidelines and what were legal
grounds for war so in the case of
Vietnam there was no declaration of war
for several reasons the first was that
the u.s. saw itself as aiding one side
in an already ongoing civil war it
didn't recognize North Vietnamese
independence and thus it had no one to
declare war on as far as the US
government was concerned it was aiding
the legitimate Vietnamese government
against an uprising not fighting a war
against any legitimate state the second
reason was the United Nations there was
no way that the USSR was going to
approve a war against a fellow communist
state and the third reason was that
domestically there was no need to you
see normally a declaration of war was
needed to implement the draft but for
America the draft from world war ii had
never technically ended after the Gulf
of Tonkin incident in which a US
destroyer in the region was attacked by
Vietnamese patrol boats Congress passed
the Gulf of Tonkin Resolution which gave
president lyndon b johnson the right to
deploy troops for combat operations
without a formal declaration of war and
after the vietnam war the u.s. never
needed to declare war because often its
conflicts were much smaller so no need
for a draft so what about the Falklands
War why didn't Margaret Thatcher declare
war on Argentina in 1982 after it sees
the Falkland Islands that should've
actually inquire as to whether or not a
declaration of war was necessary and she
was told not to and the reasons that she
was advised against such action were
simple
first of all self-defense is illegal
right according to the UN and second it
would complicate relationships with
neutral
country's neutral states aren't allowed
to provide arms for belligerence
fighting nations can't use their
territories or waters for transiting war
materials and they have to detain troops
who enter their lands along with many
other restrictions the two nations of
particular concern were Spain and Chile
Spain was against the war but had some
sympathies towards the argentinian
position plus given the placement of
Gibraltar British naval ships entering
Spanish waters by accident had to be
detained and if they weren't this could
jeopardize Spanish neutrality and as for
Chile some British troops were stationed
there for reconnaissance and if Britain
were to declare war than Chile would
legally have to detain those troops
would be considered a co-belligerent and
as for Argentina it was sourcing weapons
from other countries and getting
reconnaissance from the USSR hence why
declaration of war benefited neither
side and it's these reasons which
determined why many nations have no need
to formally declare war any more
domestic powers to fight wars are
largely much greater than they used to
be and wars are often small-scale enough
that nations don't want to deal with the
hassle of formally declaring war and yet
the main reason is that if a nation
doesn't formally declare war it doesn't
change his relationship with other
states meaning for them it's as if the
war was never happening meaning nothing
has to change I hope you enjoyed this
episode and thank you for watching with
the special thanks to my patrons James
Bissonnette John lucid a man of culture
Danny Maloney little holiday John
biscuits Rob Waterhouse mo James
Castaneda Aaron the white Jordan Longley
Gustav Swann Marcus asana rashid ali
spinning three plates filled oink oink
david silverman maggie packs Kowski
spencer Lightfoot Lexi Schwinn Kelly
moneymaker
Anthony Beckett Robert Wetzel Skye
Chappell Marvin Castle Winston Hayward
and Izzy a declaration of police action
just doesn't have the same ring to it